you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's program wildfires rage across
parts of western united states with hot
dry weather conditions
set to stay with a hundred days until
cop
26 conference in glasgow is it on course
to be a success
and a rare flower has bloomed in surrey
that could help us
understand more about our changing
climate
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions
multiple wildfires are still burning
across large parts of the united states
forcing thousands from their homes these
are the 13 states currently reporting
large fires extreme heat conditions and
a long-term drought driven by climate
change
have made it easier for the fires to
ignite and spread
now smoke from the fires has spread
across the country all the way to the
east coast and as a result
new york city now has some of the
world's worst air quality
washington philadelphia and toronto have
also been affected with the smoke
causing hazy skies and giving the moon a
red
tinge in southern oregon the bootleg
fire has been burning for
weeks and has torn across nearly 400 000
acres of land
it's now so big it's created its own
weather system
another area that's been affected is
south lake tahoe on the california
nevada border
the tamarack fire is burning through
more than 50 000
acres of land with only four percent of
it four percent
contained we're joined now by south lake
tahoe's fire chief clive savakul
uh chief savacle thank you very much
indeed for joining us at this very
testing time
how are you coping over there we have a
pretty
pretty good work force right now there's
1400 firefighters on the actual fire
itself
um it's a federal fire means the u.s
forest service
incident so they're drawing in resources
from throughout the entire western
side of the united states and they are
moving around those resources
it'd always be nice to have more but to
address that they're moving those
resources to the
most uh aggressive flanks so like right
now that's on the east side of the fire
in nevada
around highway 395 which is the main
thoroughfare between northern
and southern california and nevada now
experts are saying that
there is a direct connection between
climate change and what america is
experiencing right now in terms of
wildfires this isn't a crisis you're
anticipating in several years
it's a crisis you're fighting now is
that how it feels over there
it does there's a direct correlation
with climate change the last few years
we've had
significant increases in fire behavior
uh historically there's never been a
fire that's come from outside the lake
tahoe basin that's come into it
but because we've seen all these extreme
differences in fire
fire weather that we can't really rely
as much on the historical
incidents as we have in the past and so
kind of all bets are off
because of the climate change impacts
chief savacle we wish you all the best
with the very challenging circumstances
you're dealing with at the moment thank
you very much indeed for joining us
today
the u.s forest service has raised the
fire danger level from very high to
extreme
in the angelis national forest close to
los angeles
skies greg milam is there for us greg
thank you very much indeed
uh for joining us uh you're very
experienced at covering
wildfires in california but just how
much more concerning is the situation
not just there but
in other parts of the country this year
well in the short term the next few days
according to the forecast are going to
be hot and windy and that is bad news
for those firefighters across this
region
trying to deal with these um fires of
course they are used to it
but what's very unusual they say this
year is how early all of this
uh is is happening how many big fires
this early in the year
how quickly those fires are spreading um
five times the acreage of california has
burnt this year is at the same stage
last year and last year was the record
when they got to the end of the year so
that shows you what's going on
this extreme fire behavior they normally
see in the autumn
is happening in the early and middle
part of the summer and the reason is
pretty clear
two very dry winters there's an extreme
drought across
this part of california you can see here
in the angeles national forest
just how dry the vegetation is here and
that is a real problem and of course
there's a heat wave on top of that
drying this vegetation out even more and
providing
fuel for these fires to spread so
quickly there's also this issue of air
quality
uh the smoke that's causing problems not
surprisingly around these these fire
areas
also spreading across the country two
thousand miles away on the east coast
they're seeing the effects
of the smoke from these fires and that
is a health concern of course
for millions of people the firefighters
doing a remarkable job we have to say
that they have saved a lot of lives this
year in what they're doing
but they know more of these fires are on
their way greg thanks very much indeed
for joining us and over the weekend
there will be a special edition of the
daily climate show we'll be looking back
at the last week which has seen
extreme weather around the world prompt
yet more warnings of climate change
and on climate cast this week we explore
how we can adapt to a warming climate
you can find that wherever you normally
get your podcasts
in today's other climate news thousands
of people have been rescued after
becoming trapped by flood waters in west
india
landslides triggered by heavy monsoon
rains have killed at least five people
in maharashtra
and left hundreds stranded on rooftops
at least 30 people died after heavy
rainfall in mumbai last week
and scientists warn changing monsoon
patterns caused by climate change
will increase these extreme weather
events
the great barrier reef will not be
placed on a list of sites
in danger after the australian
government lobbied against the unesco
proposal
the world heritage committee's decision
counters scientific recommendation
which found the natural wonder at risk
from climate change
rising sea temperatures have led to
repeated bleaching
destroying at least half of the reef's
coral
and team gb's olympic athletes are being
encouraged to join the fight against
plastic pollution
flyers made from plantable seed paper
have been included in their official kit
bags
with suggestions like swapping to
reusable water bottles
today's olympics opening ceremony has
kicked off the delayed 2020 games which
organizers say
will be the greenest games yet with just
a hundred days to go until the cop 26
conference in glasgow
campaigners are urging the government to
ramp up domestic action on climate
change
protesters gathered in parliament square
in london holding posters
with suggestions that boris johnson is
missing in action cop 26 president alex
sharma says the conference is our last
best hope of avoiding the worst effects
of climate change
so what is cop 26 all about
cop 26 cop 2626 the summit that
we're holding in glasgow in november
[Music]
so
[Music]
almost every nation in the world agreed
that this was a problem
and that they would put in place
concrete steps to reduce the emissions
that were
warming our planet words are not enough
all commitments to net zero must be
underpinned by clear and credible plans
to achieve
[Music]
and politicians are already working to
turn climate promises into action
a group of lawmakers from across the
world is calling for a global green deal
ahead of cop 26. the global alliance for
a green new deal wants governments to
put measures in place that would boost
the green economy
as well as giving poorer countries
access to the finance they need
to adapt to climate change well joining
me now is caroline lucas green party mp
and one of the founding members of the
global alliance
a very warm welcome to you caroline
lucas now around 200 countries are
expected to attend cop 26
but really it's the actions of just a
few countries that could change
everything
are you confident they'll step up i
would love to say i'm confident no i'm
not confident but there's still time to
put pressure on them to try to ensure
that they do
because if they don't then i think the
future looks pretty grim
you can well imagine why many of the
poorest countries are
going to arrive in glasgow feeling
pretty pretty angry i should think
because we promised many years ago
to be providing a hundred billion
dollars a year
to those poorer countries by 2020 we are
still at least 20 billion
short of that so we haven't delivered
when it comes to the finance
and we're not delivering when it comes
to transforming our own economies fast
enough
just here in the uk we've got the
example of a government that is
looking at giving green lights to a new
oil field the cambo oil field
uh that had to be persuaded to call in a
cumbrian coal mine we still don't know
if they're going to go ahead with new
coal
but it's still going ahead with a 27
billion pound road building program
that is off course when it comes to
meeting our own climate targets the
so-called
fourth fifth and sixth carbon budgets so
when you have
the richer countries not delivering when
it comes to their own climate action
and not delivering on the finances for
the poorest countries then it shows that
we've got an
awful lot to do in the next few months
now the global alliance is calling for
this global green deal ahead of cop 26
with just 100 days to go
is that realistic well we've been
calling for a global green new deal for
a very long time what we're doing now is
coming together
as a group of lawmakers to step up the
pressure now of course
it would be wonderful if this were to
happen before cop but it doesn't have to
happen before november it needs to
happen as fast as possible but this is
an ongoing campaign
to say that one of the best ways of
transitioning
our economies away from our dependence
on fossil fuel one of the best ways of
attacking
tackling increasing inequality and
impoverished lives
is precisely through this package of
measures called a green new deal
okay caroline lucas always good to hear
your thoughts thank you very much indeed
for joining us today
and you can find out more about cop26 on
our website just head to skynews.com
forward slash climate and finally
a plant native to chile has bloomed in
surrey
years earlier than expected it could be
a sign of how rising temperatures are
affecting the
british landscape the species thorny
leaves can entangle birds and animals
earning it the nickname
the sheep eating plant skies aisha
zaheed has been to wisley to find out
more
so it's actually native to chile so it's
called pouya chilensie
as the name describes and it's generally
not something that goes through the
winter
in this part of the country very
successfully so for it to be growing
here
and flowering here is something that
we're quite proud of due to its deadly
features
the pouya chalenci is also known as the
sheep-eating plant
in their native environment they form
huge big
hummucks of these big thorny leaves so
any grazing animal
nearby could be a sheep because it's
obviously got a lot of fur
goes in for shelter and shade from the
sun and then has the ability to
basically get stuck they've got all
these big backward-facing barbs
so anything that's stuck in there stays
there decomposes but then feeds and
fertilizes the plant
climate changes a large part of why it's
flowered
just a decade ago many of these plants
wouldn't have been thriving
and if things carry on how they're going
and we do see more extreme weather
it means that the uk's landscape could
start looking a lot more exotic in the
future
i'm here with my grandchildren and yes
it does it does worry me actually that
it does seem to be getting hotter and
hotter and all the extremes of weather
that we've had this year
the floods in china and germany have
just been awful and it just makes you
realize really that we've got to do
something the more people can get around
places like this
to actually understand how into
intertwined we are with nature
the bet the better for everybody
although this is a rare sight
it's likely to become a lot more common
aisha zahid sky news
well that's everything from us for this
week but don't forget to check out our
weekly digital show
in this episode we look at why
permafrost is a hidden catastrophe
waiting to happen
that's available on sky news social
channels our app
and the website thanks for watching anna
jones will be back next week
have a great weekend